Since you were discussing head trauma are two boys were in a single vehicle accident yesterday. Oh my goodness
Everybody be praying for them
Their vehicle rolled at least five times and by the grace of God
They were both okay. They both had CT scans and everything was okay in their head and neck
But obviously suspected concussion for both anything that I should be doing for them to help their brain trauma
I've been giving them article and other homeopathic for head trauma. So I would say yes
Artica and a homeopathic for head trauma would be the thing to do, but with acute
concussions
You need to put them on
Fish oil. So EPA DHA
Barely high dose like 3000 milligrams. You need to put them on
Anti-inflammatory, so if you have the
Labinoid clear inflame. I would do high dose of that like nine to 12 a day of that
If you don't if you have curcumin at home get them on at least 3000 milligrams of curcumin
Try to get Boswellia and reservoir atrol and green t-extract as well
And then progesterone can be extremely beneficial in acute
Head traumas. So it has been shown to decrease acute inflammation in the brain progesterone
now
Issues with progesterone is that
Giddy it the sourcing it about a year and a half ago the FDA came after
Every nutritional company that was selling progesterone cream in the progesterone
Serum that you it's progesterone is typically used topically, so you'd use the serum on your belly or the cream on your belly
But that just got less lighted up again. So now you could get it quick silver has a good progesterone
And I think we have that on our store, too
And just take it as directed out there and you would just take that for a period of time now progesterone
You know, they're their boys. Why should they be taking the progesterone? It's to help with the inflammation of the brain
So I would take that for probably a month with them
The rest of those things that I mentioned I would stay on for these three months
Post-concept syndrome
That we mentioned with brain inflammation. You should probably watch that video
No, probably scary as brain inflammation and microglial primate if you just look up on our
Website pretty sure it's on the member site. I know it's on a chronic disease in an autoimmune site
But it's definitely on our website if you just start searching brain inflammation
I think it is as you'll see the video it's one half hour video that explains what that is and how to
Deal with it mainly you know a couple years later, but to a cute
I don't really go through a cute trouble with that, but I just explained that so
Yes with the cute concussive syndrome those are the things that you would look at and you're you want to try to decrease that inflammation because you don't want
You know long-term issues that are going to cause issues and they should probably go into a chiropractor that takes x-rays